bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france comment avez vous
accueilli cette annonce c'est un
soulagement pour les femmes égyptiennes
oui d'abord bonjour ravi d'être avec
vous oui un soulagement
certainement mais pas seulement une
attente surtout nous sommes soulagés oui
parce qu'il était temps que les peines
donc atteigne les 5 et 7 ans pour
l'heure seulement il faudra aussi voir
prolos violent et serra
mais nous attendons le reste il va nous
falloir encore d'autres combats pour
atteindre au moins mais dont des mesures
par exemple de protection de ses
victimes après les actes et des de
bebeto donne dommage mais des espèces de
deux aides
un psychologique financière le
harcèlement est devenu un phénomène
ce n'est plus un acte perpétré dans la
rue c'est vrai comme partout dans le
monde pareil mais ici ça devient un vrai
phénomène
et ce depuis malheureusement 2011 1 nous
nous sommes nous avons affaire à des est
pratiquement des hordes 1
il est vrai que si on remonte comme vous
le disiez à 2011 on se souvient de ces
agressions collective de femmes sur la
place talent et est ce que ça avait jeté
la lumière sur ce phénomène en egypte ah
oui absolument c'était c'était quelque
chose d'aberrant parce que c'était du
jamais vu voyez-vous et donc ça a
commencé place tahrir comme vous le
dites exactement à l'est des viols au
groupe des choses horribles comme qu'on
n'avait jamais vécu en gîte est un petit
peu comme un lancement un projet qui
commençait donc jeu
personnellement je considère cette cet
enjeu dire phénomène ce phénomène comme
quelque chose de très voulu un il ya
déjà des entités sociales peut-être
politiques qui ont commencé à déferler
dans les rues d'egypte du caire surtout
été happé dans toute l'île en 2000 ans
en 2014
je je faisais partie du comité des coûts
du comité femmes au sein de la
commission de 50 la rédaction la de la
constitution 2014 et donc le fameux tarp
article 11 donc les droits de la femme
la protection il s'agit maintenant non
pas de deux d'augmenter les droits de la
femme mais de récupérer des droits qu'on
a perdus après de milandre et surtout
d'où vient cette de vous expliquer
comment comment est venue cette demande
en coulisses un de criminaliser le
harcèlement sexuel de durcir le ton face
aux agresseurs est ce que il n'ya pas
aussi une part du mouvement me to qui a
eu des conséquences à l'international
oui probablement oui oui mais pas
retenant sa ce mouvement international
va uniquement
à cete les égyptiennes qui sont ensuite
sur leur portable ou l'orage machin
enfin en gagne alors que la majorité
payne les égyptiens ne sont pas donc ne
font pas partie de ces réseaux sociaux
et ne sont pas vraiment connecté dans le
sens moderne du terme
nous parlons de deux des provinces
parlant des zones rurales et les zones à
population très dense donc la
haute-egypte et ses pirates ces gens là
ne compte ne savent pas toujours ce que
c'est lui tout un par contre vous
parliez de prix dans toutes les sphères
féministe impasse que veut pas vraiment
pu min nous avons fait vrai déni t-il
des rallidés des réunions toute la halle
dans lesquelles vous et la famille
révélé de l'egypte sont les problèmes -
au moins cinq ans de prison
je vous parle de ses peines d'au moins
cinq ans de prison contre un an et demi
minimum auparavant circonstance
aggravante ça va passer à au moins sept
ans de prison est ce que c'est assez
selon vous est aussi est-ce que vous
pensez que dans les faits ça va être
réellement établie concernant les
agresseurs
ajoutons que ce n'est pas assez
déjà pour répondre très simplement votre
question c'est passé du tout parce que
il ya seulement harcèlement il faut voir
que dans la rue égyptienne maintenant
nous avons des cas très très compliqué
hier c'est le harcèlement verbal il ya
physique bien toi même temps c'est
triste mais c'est vraiment comme ça ça
ne s'est pas assez compte pour pouvoir
déjà avoir des vrais cas et d'aller
devant le tribunal il va falloir qu'on
fasse beaucoup plus dans la rue il faut
beaucoup plus de sûreté beaucoup plus
d'officiers je me demande comment ils
vont faire ça parce que l'egypte cet
immense 1 500 millions et ce phénomène
est malheureusement très présent
maintenant dix ans est ce que vous
pensez peut-être savoir d'une source
il faut aller aux sources du problème il
faut voir il faut il faut trouver ce que
ça va dit signifiant qu'ils convoient
rada est-ce que ça va attirer des
lecteurs
il faut il faut voir les chefs de groupe
et ce sont les vrais gang en triste mais
je pense honnêtement et sincèrement et à
créer une expérience dans la muraille
tous les jours je fais face à ça je suis
sûr il y a moyen d'arrêter ça à la
source
il ya donc des groupes de personnes qui
font qu'ils ont des vrais emplois du
temps qu ils ont des cartes il envoie
les gens dans des quartiers précise
il doit y avoir un moyen de faire ça
autrement on va pas attendre une file et
d'une fille se fasse à harceler une dame
dans la rue pour s'occuper du problème
il faut aller à la source
je le dis et je peux pas tous les jours
pour ça merci beaucoup merci
un rabat el wakil pour toutes vos
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
rédactrice en chef du magazine
francophone culture est là et
chroniqueuse au journal le progrès
égyptien merci à vous